if you're an artist type who lives in a
city like Seattle or in a city but
especially one of the coast cities it is
just so much easier to tow the
Democratic party line and go along with
whatever it is our dear leader wants us
to believe it hi I'm Zach why similar
for reason TV I'm here with Peter bag
cartoonist author and reason contributor
his latest graphic novel is available
for purchase now it's called reset and
his next work Peter bags other stuff
comes out this May Peter thank you very
much for joining us sure reset which is
very funny entertaining sometimes dark
work follows the story of a washed-up
comedian and actor named guy crass who
stumbles into a virtual reality
experiment which allows him to kind of
redo certain parts of his life
the basic premise has kind of been
explored before in film and literature
but your twist on it is he doesn't get
very far at times he gets stopped by
technological and human obstacles what
inspired you to tell this story
originally with the story I wanted to
delve into pure fantasy the age-old and
played-out idea of reliving your life
going back in time and doing things over
again so I started from that point and
as I worked out the idea in my head I
had a very difficult time staying in the
world of fantasy I it just wasn't
working for me I would I would get a bit
bored and restless it seemed a little
too loosey-goosey I guess I need those
boundaries that we call reality not to
give too much away but the experimenters
have some very specific ideas about how
they want the virtual reality technology
to be used and our character guy doesn't
really follow that path he does some
things that they find repellent and even
disgusting right do you find parallels
to this in the real world I mean it
seems like often individuals end up
using technology in a way that's
different than what the creator's
intended
well this isn't doesn't stray too far
from what happens in the book that what
you mentioned is the disgusting part
it's how often somebody does develop any
kind of new technology one of the first
things that's used if if not the first
thing it's used for is pornography that
happens time and time again and then and
then it becomes almost synonymous with
pornography whatever this technology is
and then it it's other uses tend to stem
from there but that's like one of the
driving forces for it which i doubt is
ever in the minds of the people who came
up with the technology that's being used
I mean do you think it's fair for
someone who creates a certain kind of
technology to feel disgusted or repelled
by how people end up using the actual
technology for their own sake they
should approach the whole thing with an
open mind of course they have the right
to be upset or disappointed but yeah the
wisest thing to do is to have a
completely open mind and be ready for
any results and they might have gotten
completely different in fact I'm sure
they would have gotten very different
results from a different test subject
someone more pliable perhaps because the
main character here is anything but
pliable for recent magazine you draw
politically themed stories where there's
often a very specific point or message
you're trying to get across when you're
trying to tell a story like reset I read
a lot of anti-authoritarian
individualist type themes right how much
of that is you're consciously trying to
get across a political or social
commentary and how much is just kind of
a natural outgrowth of your personality
as a storyteller well with the story
like we said I'm trying first and
foremost to entertain and engage the
readers so the last thing you want to do
in that regard is to preach or be too
heavy-handed and impose your political
opinions on the reader because chances
are the reader won't agree and they'll
just be turned off and annoyed but of
course my political opinions and my
worldview go hand-in-hand for example in
this story reset you the extent to which
the government is involved with the
otherwise private business concerning
the mixture of the two it's just in my
opinion you know private public
partnerships always end in disaster
it's not get another word for boondoggle
and and I don't it's that's not just
being lazy that's just not lazy thinking
in my part but that just almost always
turns out to be the case and of course
that and again that wasn't my point to
illustrate that in the story but of
course that that comes across in the
story just because to me that's as
natural as you know the Sun rising in
the east the comics world and publishing
more broadly have seen their fair share
resets in the course of your career
which stretches back to the 1980s have
revolutions in production technology
improved products or or had the opposite
effect
and and how has it affected you mostl
radical change in the last 10 20 years
is the internet and on one hand
especially as consumers it's been
fantastic it's a godsend you have the
world at your fingertips and your other
than once you've paid for the
infrastructure your pretty much can get
almost anything for free or almost free
but as a producer of art if that's the
real conundrum because revenue streams
have dried up people give me all kinds
of suggestions about how you could
exploit the Internet or someone like me
could exploit the Internet to make money
but so far everything that's been
suggested to me just for my sake have
not been very practical they really
don't work so I add something that I
still have to figure out and soon how is
the internet affected comics
specifically do you think that they've
improved in recent years or gotten worse
or no effect at all
well I operate in the world of which
generally called alternative comics
which pretty much means anything that
isn't genre fiction that's not
superheroes I noticed there's more
people doing that than ever before and
you see a wide variety of artists and
approaches that that seems to be
exploding and I can't help but think the
Internet has something to do with that
because when I started out in the early
80s it was impossible for your work for
my work to be seen let alone sold to
most people in the country you had to
live in very specific places to even be
aware of the fact that comics like mine
existed your rare among alternative
artists not only that you're not a
traditional liberal but you're not a
reactionary conservative either like Al
Capp the creator of little Abner whose
biography you actually recently reviewed
in Reason magazine you are hardcore
libertarian in favor of legalizing drugs
immigration lower taxes so what's wrong
with you what is wrong with the creative
class that is so doctrinaire left if
you're an artist type who lives in a
city like Seattle or in a city but
especially one of the coast cities it is
just so much easier to tow the
Democratic party line and go along with
whatever it is our dear leader wants us
to believe in it life just goes along
that much more smoother it's it's a way
of not making waves we ran to Paul's
filibuster the whole point of which
ultimately was to get the Obama
administration to tell us exactly what
their plans are as far as killing
American citizens on American so I don't
think they should be killing
non-combatants anywhere ever yeah but
and it seems like such a simple
situation to understand and and still
I'm flabbergasted at how many people
can't get past that fact that Rand
Paul's a Republican and how they all of
a sudden they sound like George Bush
Peter bag thank you for joining us
really appreciate it
sure thank you